[Musique]
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup beaucoup
parce qu'il voit depuis 5e bull est
d'être présidente départementale des
jeunes est donc là bas aujourd'hui je
suis élu et je suis très très contente
jirel gouraya blue salarié a reculé bien
son nom c'est la nouvelle président du
conseil départemental des jeunes ces
collégiennes de saint charles à saint
pierre a été plébiscité par les être
enfin représentants de chaque collège
des dînes chaque collégien a pu voter en
ligne en raison la pandémie
effectivement commis 19
nous avons dû faire preuve
d'adaptabilité complexité également un
appui de tête de modernité puisque nous
avons organisé un vol entre distance
yonne shirel qui soit investir les
problématiques du réchauffement
climatique et de la pollution des plages
elle sera secondé dans ses engagements à
maera lacny du collège hippolyte foucque
de son fuseau et lucie et 3 du collège
has a scoré de cilaos
le conseil départemental des jeunes une
opportunité à saisir pour la 8ème vice
présidente du département en charge des
collèges et de l'éducation
le débat est tout vert où la parole est
libérée il faut qu'aujourd'hui nous
ayons
ness qui veut à tout prix de s'investir
des citoyennes s'investir dans des
instances comme le conseil départemental
parmi les sujets qui feront partie des
débats pour cette mandature 2020 2021
le harcèlement à l'école pour combattre
ce fléau le cd jeunes a invité chiodi
demi-finalistes l'oeil ce guide a été
bonne pour moi c'est important pour
montrer à mon harceleur que pendant une
période de malaise de la pub est à voir
au plus bas que terre il faut dire et
maintenant dans ces acides à madame télé
voilà ce pas le contraire c'est que
malgré le harcèlement que j'ai eus que
j'ai reçus suite ça ben je ne suis pas
rabaisser c est ma tête est toujours a
été relevé avec malabo et l'aide des
mamans bien sûr j'avais fait n'était pas
viable
aujourd'hui je pense pas que je serai là
où je suis maintenant
diddy qui a reçu la médaille
départementale du mérite
le combi chouchou la batterie sterling
du jeune chanteur a résonné dans
l'hémicycle du département shirel jody
de parcours pour une même cause
libérer la parole que ce soit pour
chanter ou encore pour prendre ma
défense des plus faibles
être médecin urgentiste
mais c'est sûr qu'en ce moment je
réfléchis entre médecine et sciences po
et finalement je me suis dis pas
ministre de la santé combiner les deux
ce serait chouette
donc voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]